la mayor ola cubana migratoria de la
historia así califican las autoridades
fronterizas estadounidenses el 2022
cuando según datos oficiales de
diciembre de 2021 a diciembre de 2022 se
registraron más de 227.000 casos de
cubanos ingresando irregularmente al
país muchos han precipitado el viaje
ante el miedo a las estrictas leyes de
entrada nosotros nos apresuramos y creo
que también le pasó lo mismo a muchas de
las tantas personas que han llegado
recientemente que todas tienen o
teníamos el temor de que cerraran la
frontera los migrantes optan por dos
vías muchas controladas por mafias la
primera es por Nicaragua donde no
necesitan visa desde 2021 Y a dónde
llegan por aire Desde allí por tierra
siguen hasta la frontera entre México y
Estados Unidos es un viaje que puede
durar 30 días y costar hasta 7000
dólares la segunda opción
informar arriesgando su vida durante 145
kilómetros en embarcaciones improvisadas
con destino Florida viajes que no
siempre tienen éxito Con múltiples
accidentes y más de 3.700 cubanos
detenidos por la guardia costera entre
octubre de 2021 y 2022 con una cantidad
tan grande de personas que están
llegando repentinamente con una economía
que efectivamente acaba de salir del
covid o está saliendo del covid se hace
difícil no poder integrar a tantos
inmigrantes recién llegados
Cuba ha visto un deterioro de su
economía desde la pandemia de Kobe 19
esta trajo también una disminución del
turismo una de las principales entradas
de Divisas al país